[Music]
morning everybody it is seven o'clock
here in the uk welcome wherever you're
watching us around the world this
morning
royal rifts and a russian rumble over a
warship
plenty of stories to ask the environment
secretary george eustis about it just a
few moments time class
will any holiday islands be flying onto
the green list later on today
the shadow business secretary ed
miliband is also on the programme
and we're joined by the u.s blogger
perez hilton to talk about britney
spears attempt
to take back control of her life also
this morning for you a standoff at sea
we'll talk through the clash between
russian and british naval forces with
the former chief of the general staff
lord richard dannet that is at
half past eight this morning plus the
chipped
nails you would love to have or not
perhaps we'll talk to the beautician
who's come up with a novel way of
storing your personal
data it's thursday the 24th of june
revealed the royal accounts that show
prince charles gave the duke and duchess
of sussex
a substantial sum of money despite a
claim
from harry to the country
hey
i want my life back britney spears tells
the court she was
forced to use birth control against her
will as she tries to end her father's
control of her life are the traffic
lights about to change
government sources suggest some spanish
holiday islands could make it onto the
green list
as the government prepares to update us
counting the cost of climate change we
investigate how much it might cost you
to get your heist in order
and 25 years after the 1996 heartbreak
england will play the old enemy in euro
2020
at wembley
eastern europe and russia seeing
record-breaking temperatures
at the moment not quite so warm here and
indeed over the weekend it's likely to
be northern parts of the country
that see the better weather all the
weather details coming up with me very
shortly
[Music]
quite the show for you this morning
don't know how we're going to pack it
all in we'll give it a good go
one of the claims that shocked the world
let's start with that when the duke
of sussex told oprah winfrey during an
interview with his wife
that his family had cut him off
financially
royal accounts published this morning
have revealed that prince charles gave
the couple a substantial sum of money in
the months after they stepped down from
royal duties
our royal correspondent rhiannon mills
reports
in recent years they had appeared to
grow closer but then came the claims
from
harry that his father and family
literally
cut him off financially when they
decided to step away from royal life
except now accounts show that prince
charles did continue
to give the sussexes money a senior
clarence house spokesperson
said the prince of wales allocated a
substantial sum to support them with
this transition
they added that funding ceased in the
summer of last year
the couple are now financially
independent
a spokesperson for the sussexes denied
there was a contradiction
saying the comments made during the
oprah interview were aligned
with the timeline that clarence house
referenced
i wrote a piece in which i had spoken to
people close to prince of wales to
reflect
his surprise at the comments that harry
said he was financially cut off
the quote used for me was the prince was
very surprised to hear that he's seen
the bank statements
the palace accounts also include the 2.4
million pounds that harry and megan
paid back in relation to frogmore
cottage the huge cost to refurbish it
but the figures show the money
hasn't just been used to cover the
refurbishment but also put towards their
rent
the sussex spokesperson said the duke
has made a substantial contribution to
the sovereign grant
and all tenant obligations are being met
it was another allegation from the
sussexes that rocked the royals this
year
and for the first time the palace have
released their diversity figures
not a knee-jerk reaction to harry and
megan's claims they say but part of an
ongoing drive to do more
with 8.5 of their workforce currently
from ethnic minorities
they want that boosted to 10 by next
year
the accounts show just how much covid
has shaped
everything they've done along with the
family fallout
it has made it a challenging year
rhiannon mills
sky news
we're going to be speaking about that in
more detail uh later on
um so remember they said that they
didn't get any money they were cut off
financially it does look from those
latest figures
although substantial storms were still
given to
um harry and megan after they left the
royal household more on that to come
also at 7 45
talk through the remarkable evidence
given by britney spears in court
overnight with showbiz blogger perry's
hilton that to come
labour says the government will struggle
to meet its target on climate change the
shadow of business secretary ed miliband
will join us at five past eight
how realistic is the government's key
environmental target of banning
all gas boilers in the next four years
plumber
and entrepreneur charlie mullins will be
here
at 8 20.
before all that though let's uh bring in
george eustis should we uh just uh
joining us secretary of state for the
environment food and rural affairs of
course thanks for rushing in
it's always a rush in the morning um
let's start with the monarchy that's
what we're leading on on our program
this morning 87.5
million pounds is how much they cost the
taxpayer last year
why they still value for money well i
think the system that we have
with a constitutional monarchy is way
better than all the alternatives better
than presidential systems
it means you have that um stability
you have a monarch that can bring the
country together i think the royal
family
is good value for money it's a vital
part of our constitution always has been
charles has suggested a further slimming
down
of the senior royals do you think that's
a good idea well look this
is something obviously that the the
royal family themselves look at they've
got a budget like everybody else
i've seen some of the speculation about
changes they're making
events they're doing and so on um
they've got to operate within a budget
and obviously they will manage that role
household
last time i saw you i was heading down
to cornwall you said you were going to
go there for your holly bobs this year
um we will find out later on what's
going to be put on the green list i know
you're not going to tell me before that
so there's pointless
uh asking but how pleased would you be
if the spanish islands were added
well look um personally i i want us to
get back to a position where we can
support those
uh who want to travel to do so nobody
likes the draconian restrictions we've
had to put in place over this
last years we've wrestled with the
pandemic so yes we want to get to a
position where we can support
people who want to travel to be able to
do so but it is difficult we are being
cautious because
the biggest threat still to our progress
against this pandemic and the great
progress we've made on vaccination
is that there will be another variant
somewhere that maybe hadn't been
properly
detected in another country and that
that variant is more resistant to the
vaccination so that's the that's the
great
um challenge that we've got that's why
we are proceeding with caution but
obviously grant shaps will say more
later
yeah i mean we are being told that the
balearic islands
and malta and i think madeira as well um
are
going to be added later on do you think
the islands should be
treated differently to to the mainland
of spain portugal or wherever um
well not necessarily because obviously
between islands there's a lot of
travel to other countries um but if
you've got
islands where travel is more you know
travel is more restricted and you can
tell that and you've got a very low
prevalence of the virus there and you've
got a high degree of confidence well
then obviously that's something you look
like you can look at
um many of the countries we've already
got on the green list are islands
you know some of them very small islands
admittedly sansa say you've been a bit
of a stick in the muddy
because we were thinking that we were
going to find these islands were going
to be on the list later on but from what
you're saying
you're being a proper doubting thomas
well what i'm really saying uh okay is
that you know um grant shaps
is leading on this uh he'll be saying
more about it later
uh and i'm not in a position uh at this
stage to to tell you what he may or may
not say as you as you speculated at the
beginning
okay okay um we had the uh media
minister on yesterday and he said it was
acceptable for important people like
uefa officials not to have to isolate
when they come
to this country to go to wembley what
qualifies as important
well um okay i presume it's officials
that are um
directly involved in making that event
happen and again
this is an area where you know we want
to be able to facilitate uh this event
it's a big
important sporting event sports been
heavily disrupted over the last year
like every other
facet of life we want to be able to
support this tournament to go
ahead and that's why in all of these
areas we will sometimes
take different approaches using testing
for instance um
regular testing lateral flow testing as
an alternative in some instances
and i i think you know we do sometimes
need to do this to try to
facilitate the return to normality and
life as normal
so are my viewers less important because
they want to go to ibiza
well it's not that it's um it's a
question of scale really and you could
say the same about
for instance the g7 event and people did
raise questions about that but
that was bringing a a relatively small
number of people together
uh for an important meeting to discuss
global challenges including the pandemic
and what we put in place there were
systems where you know you had very
intensive uh lateral flow testing to to
make sure that uh people
attending that event did not get the
virus it was monitored very closely
it was a slightly different uh approach
that was taken
um but all of the measures were taken
case is rocketed though didn't they in
cornwall
uh yes but they're not linked to the um
leading to g7 there have been some
increases as there are
right around the country um because
obviously we've got getting a large
proportion of
the population the younger population
are only now being vaccinated so over
the last uh four weeks as we've
been in a different situation if people
have been moving around while some of
them haven't been vaccinated okay let's
uh talk about what happened
uh to hms defender yesterday if you
wouldn't mind
um shots fired for the benefit of my
viewers by the russians the hms defender
after entered uh disputed territorial
waters what were we doing there in the
first place
well it's under international law um you
can take the
the the sort of closest fastest route
from one point to another
uh hms defender was passing through
ukrainian waters i think on the way to
georgia and that was the
logical route for it to take i'm told
that actually this is quite
um you know this is a very normal thing
it's quite common
actually what was actually going on is
the the russians were doing a gunnery
exercise they'd given
prior notice of that they often do in
that area
so i think it's important people don't
get carried away well apparently uh no
there weren't
um warning shots apparently this was
something quite different which was
there's a gunnery exercise
that was going on prior warning was
dropped in front of the boat no that
didn't happen well that's i wasn't there
uh but i'm told that journalists on the
boat and they said that's what happened
yes well i'm told that's not what
happened so i'm you know i've um i've
spoken to abc
and the daily mail reporters both said
that that's what happened well
are you disputing their claims well i'm
saying that these were
um insofar as you know i don't think
there were warning shots there was a
gunnery exercise that was taking place
and it's not uncommon for the russians
to to do this in this area um
and um therefore the you know the
incident's not um
particularly abnormal in that sense okay
um
it is disputed territory nonetheless
disputed waters what is the benefit
in us poking the russian bear at the
moment
um well there's a convention in
international law that a vessel can take
the most direct route from one point to
another
and we were passing through um ukrainian
territorial waters would we do it again
of course yes even though we saw what
happened when hms defender took that
rock
yes because we don't accept um you know
that um
the annexation really isn't it we don't
accept we never accepted the
uh annexation of uh of crimea um
these were ukrainian territorial waters
okay and if they did
uh attempt to stop us doing that again
in whatever fashion depending on on
which
account you accept what should we do to
retaliate
well look um i'm not getting really into
that what i would say well because
that's a hypothetical question and the
point is because we saw what happened
yesterday well um
what i'm told happened yesterday is that
russia gave prior notice that they were
running a gunnery exercise in that area
everybody understood that they knew that
was happening and then what actually was
happening is hms defender was
uh making a passage through ukrainian
territorial waters and the crew
uh prepared for a possible uh hostile
confrontation they had to put on their
suits
that are designed for if there's a fire
on board or whatever
uh the uh journalist also describing
hostile warnings over the radio
well um look you get these uh these
sorts of incidents around that area i'm
told that it's quite common for russia
to run
exercises of that sort obviously there's
been tensions between
the uk and other allies in russia for
some time
over issues like crimea but um
i don't think there's anything in this
particular event that people should get
too
carried away by this was simply the case
that hms defender was passing through
ukrainian territorial waters uh the
russians have given us prior notice that
they were doing this gunnery exercise
and don't threaten us uh we'll do it
again if we want to and um
just back off well um i think russia
understands international law on this
which is
our vessels are uh you know permitted to
take that shortest possible route uh on
what's called innocent passage through
waters
that's a yes isn't it well it's it's a
statement of what international law is
that you can travel
um on the shortest route um for innocent
passage and that's understood in
uh international marine law okay let me
ask you about terminus day if
i may uh we had dr david nabarro from
the world health organization
on uh yesterday um he says even after
the 19th of
july we still need to uh socially
distance and we need to wear our masks
uh
even inside what do you think well look
what we want to do
on the 19th of july and the prime
minister said that
the data looks good to be able to have
that end is to remove all of the
legal restrictions that's all of the
legal requirements to do things
to be taken away completely now whether
there will still be some people who
might choose to wear masks or whether
it may be advisory in some settings
that's a separate matter but the
the objective of that final stage
is to remove the legal requirement to do
these things okay so from the 19th of
july we won't have to wear our masks
inside as far as the government's
concerned
well as far as because there won't be a
legal compulsion for you too would you
um i wouldn't no i have to be honest i
uh
once i'm told that it's safe not to i
want to get back to normal
i think a lot of people will want to um
shed those masks
but um while it's um contributing to
controlling the pandemic uh
yes i will wear my mask like everybody
else and obviously do my bit
talk to us about areas of outstanding
natural beauty that's what you want to
chat to about uh today isn't it where
will they be
well we have uh four um areas that we're
looking at
an extension uh of one uh in um in
surrey
and uh uh in the in the cotswolds and
then uh two
one in uh yorkshire world and one in
cheshire that will be
new designations we've got a commitment
to protect
30 of our terrestrial land by 2030 and
so
having these additional areas of
outstanding natural beauty will
contribute to that
and we're also today responding to a
review that was done by julian glover
into our national parks and protected
landscapes
where there was a recommendation that we
should do more for nature in those areas
and so we'll be
seeking to do more of that through our
future agriculture policy
more to encourage public access and
we've announced the fund today to
support that and also to sort of close
the gap if you like between areas of
outstanding natural beauty
and national parks in terms of the
attention they get and the awareness
about them
now we know that you appreciate our uh
investigative journalism here at sky
and we've got a report running this
morning about tar lagoons 34 of them in
the uk
damaging wildlife and detrimental to the
environment um apparently it's very easy
to fix we need to plant willows and the
like this is uh some of the images that
we've got from
nz rasheed's piece will you
consider looking at the options to clean
up the countryside in areas like this
yes i mean our whole change to policy
is about on agriculture in particular
it's about moving to a more regenerative
system
where we can use natural capital natural
assets things like trees to
help tackle some of the environmental
challenges whether that's climate change
whether that's biodiversity
and it's absolutely the case that
sometimes natural systems including
simple things like tree planting
can deal with some of these other uh
issues that we've got other issues of
pollution so
absolutely i'm happy to take that
particular challenge away and look at it
because
it's absolutely the central piece if you
like of government policy on the
environment we would very much
appreciate that it's always a pleasure
thank you for joining us this morning
thank you
still to come on the program for you
this morning
as we were saying government sources
have suggested to us that the blair
and malta may be added to the travel
green list today becky cottrell standing
by for us
at heathrow hello to you becky tell us
more
well we understand from government
sources that malta
and the balearic islands will be added
to the green list
when it is updated today you were just
trying to uh push the minister on that
but he was being
rather coy but we understand that will
be the case these are popular
tourist destinations in normal times
more than five million brits would
travel
to ibiza majorca and menorca so if you
do want to go and they are added to the
list you would still have to do a test
before you leave and before you arrive
back
but you would be able to avoid that
quarantine
european countries are concerned about
rising cases of the delta variant in the
uk
uh german chancellor angela merkel
saying she would like
british travelers arriving anywhere in
europe to have to quarantine when they
land
like they currently do in germany one
other thing we're also looking out for
an announcement on potentially today
potentially not
uh is this hint from the health
secretary that people who are fully
vaccinated will be able to avoid
quarantine
potentially by doing daily coronavirus
tests we've heard it might be
from august so that is something to look
out for today
something that ministers will probably
be discussing uh but it's not clear
whether that will be confirmed or not
okay for now thank you thanks a lot
uh of course we will as soon as we hear
from the government on that whether or
not you can book
your holidays this year it will be here
on sky news first
now forced to take birth control treated
like a slave
and bullied these are the claims made by
britney spears
in a dramatic court hearing last night
as she appealed against an
order which gives her father control
over many aspects of her life
she said she wants her life back her
father um
greg milam actually was in court she had
not appeared in court greg milan was
there
and sent this report which contains
flash photography
for the fans who mobilized in their
words to free brittany
the audio feed from inside court brought
confirmation
of what they've been saying all along
[Applause]
they listened to a star performer
telling a story she says that until now
has been silenced
[Music]
for 13 years she's been the subject to a
conservatorship
handing control of her life to her
family and the lawyers
in the space of 20 minutes in court she
savaged them all
i truly believe this conservatorship is
abusive she said
i'm not here to be anyone's slave i'm
traumatized
the conservators had prevented her from
getting married or having more children
she said
adding i feel ganged up on and i feel
bullied
and i feel left out and alone and i'm
tired of feeling alone
i deserve to have the same rights having
a child or any of those
things she compared her treatment to
being sex trafficked
and said she was depressed and cried
every day she alleged her medication had
been changed without her knowledge
after she disagreed with a dance move
and on the conservatorship she said
it's my wish and dream for all this to
end she added
i want my life back it was undoubtedly
explosive at the outset britney spears
told the court she had a lot to say
and she delivered at one point the judge
told her she had to slow down because
the court stenographer couldn't keep up
with the pace of what she was saying
the system has done a good job
exploiting me britney spears said
i should be able to speak
it is another dramatic chapter in a life
of very public highs and lows
this one especially significant for her
supporters
it is disgraceful that they have put
britney spears
through the trauma exploitation and
abuse
that she has been put through i am so
sorry my darling britney
that you have been put through this
we've been doing this for years we've
come
to every single hearing since you know
april 2019
so to hear that we've been right and
that everything we thought was true
is extremely vindicating one of the
conservators is britney's father jamie
he was listening in as she attacked him
during the hearing
his lawyer said he was sorry to see his
daughter suffering and in so much pain
but she has now begun the process of
securing the freedom
she wants britney's voice has finally
been heard
greg is with us now live in la this
morning hello to you greg so what
happens next to brittany
yeah it's not entirely clear i mean she
obviously made very clear in in that
hearing today in those 23 minutes what
she wants to happen which is the end of
that conservatorship
there is another hearing due to take
place in in july
a lot of what she talked about today was
wanting it to end without any more
medical evaluations normally a doctor
would be called in
to end one of these conservative
conservatorships to say the person was
fit to end it
she has said she doesn't want to go
through any more of that and believes
the judge can order that she doesn't
have to so
that's one key thing she has to make a
formal representation through her lawyer
uh for it to end so that is the next key
key phase
for her her lawyer has said and he was
surprised by what she said today as well
has said that having gone on the record
publicly today she now wants
future hearings to be sealed so not
revealed to the public so we might not
get much more information
about what happens next but she made it
very clear and i think she surprised not
only everyone in court with what she
said today
but even some of those very fervent free
britney campaigners a lot of them have
been saying all of this for a long time
but i don't think they felt she would go
that far and go into that much detail
particularly about
private medical stuff i think they were
taken by surprise but they're very
pleased and i think they see it as
vindication because
they've been told for a long time this
is none of their business they should
stay out of this
but they believe that they were right
all along and britney spears has given
them that today
okay thanks greg thanks a lot
reports from onboard a british warship
suggest that russian forces did fire
warning shots to chase the vessel out of
waters off the coast
of the crimea peninsula although we did
speak to um george eustis a short while
ago and he
has a different account he said that
that didn't happen that wasn't the
recollection
of those on board however that account
um
has also been challenged by the ministry
of defense who say the shots fired were
part of a russian
exercise and that no bombs had been
dropped that's not what journalists on
board said
the russian defense ministry said shots
were fired in the path of the
defender as it sailed 12 miles off
the coast it's certainly uh in disputed
waters but we did hear from george
eustis representing the government this
morning
saying that the british would do it
again and it was not poking
the russian bear let's see what happens
next going to be talking about the
forelight from that dramatic encounter
with the former chief of the general
staff lord richard dannett
he's going to be here at half past eight
also making news for you this morning
and a government study into long covid
says more than two million people in
england have suffered from the condition
the most common symptoms were tiredness
shortness of breath
and chest pain for people who have
reported
having symptoms of covet at all about
38 of them go on to have some persisting
symptoms
and that's more common in women than men
about 50 more likely
um in women it increases with age so
for every 10 years older you get about
three and a half percent more people
will get long
symptoms and it's also more common in
people who live in deprived
areas and who have low incomes
the latest figures show rise in
coronavirus cases
with 16 135 new infections
the highest number since february 19
more deaths have been reported that
means the total number of people
who've died within 28 days of a positive
test
now stands at 128 027.
vaccinations for you almost 300 000
people
have received their yeah 300
000 first vaccines and 250
875 people have received their
second total number of those double
vaccinated has passed 60
of adults 31 million
we might all want to make our homes a
bit greener to help fight climate change
but
how much would that actually cost
thousands that's how much to pay for
things such as replacing old boilers
with
heat pumps our science correspondent
thomas more reports
jan could be a poster boy for the green
transition we all need to make
he has an electric car out front a low
carbon heat pump instead of a gas boiler
and he even ripped off the plaster to
insulate his victorian terrace
the upgrades to the house alone cost 13
000
pounds even after government grants for
many people this would be
a lot of money to pay and very difficult
to pay
but i think the government needs to
provide support to enable people not
just the wealthy but everybody to do
this because we need to do it
the government's own climate advisors
today warn ministers are failing to live
up to promises to cut the country's
emissions
there's still no plan on how to replace
millions of boilers
encourage people to drive electric and
keep homes cool
as global temperatures rise the
government is not helping itself by not
setting out plans here so we don't have
a plan or a strategy that
people can look at and can understand
people so that people can make sensible
decisions about
you know big decisions that will have to
be taken over the course of the next 10
15 years in our daily lives
wind and solar have significantly cut uk
carbon emissions but the economy is
still largely dependent on fossil fuels
the pandemic shut down centers kept cars
off the roads and grounded aircraft
but despite all that the uk's carbon
emissions in 2020 only fell
by 13 we still spewed out more than
400 million tons it shows just how much
work will be needed
to get emissions down to net zero
campaigners say the world's eyes will be
on the uk ahead of the glasgow climate
summit in november
and the talks could fail without a clear
plan
people will be looking to the uk to have
bold actions in place
at cop26 and really to be a leader and
we need to start seeing that we risk
falling behind and missing out on
green jobs the government denied that it
has been slow to deliver on climate
action
strategies on how to green the economy
and our lifestyles
will be published later this year thomas
more sky news
and for more stories on the environment
and climate change watch the daily
climate show every evening 6 30 and 9 30
and you can download and listen to the
latest edition of our weekly climate
cast podcast
available now wherever you get your
podcast from
it's 1996 all over
again england will play germany at
wembley
in the last 16 of euro 2020
germany finished second in group f after
a late
equaliser saw them uh come from behind
to draw
two two with hungary
26 years after gary southgate missed the
penalty
which put germany into the finals the
two sides will meet next wednesday
at wembley
please please please please don't let it
go to penalties it was a lovely day
yesterday actually wasn't it what's it
going to do today let's find out here's
joe good morning joe
not quite so good today i'm afraid and
indeed over the next few days it's going
to be southern parts of the country that
actually sees the worst of the weather
northern parts
should see some sunshine let's uh take a
look at the pictures then
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning well it does
look as though southeastern parts of the
country will have a fine start to the
day once again
but then there's more coming cloud
patchy rain more persistent rain
up towards the far northwest and the
whole lot is shifting its way
southward so it's a very mixed untidy
sort of picture today
there's our sunshine in the south chilly
start temperatures in single figures
milder in the clouds through central
areas outbreaks of patchy rain
more intense rain up towards the
northwest with strong winds gusting to
30 or 40 miles per hour
and the whole lot just sliding its way
southward so you see we will see some
sunshine over southern parts of ireland
also northern england parts of wales
down towards the southwest
and the sunshine in the southeast
gradually being eroded
by that cloud from the north as the day
goes on uh
again we see the cloud taking over much
of the southeast at
some further outbreaks of rain some
sunshine for these northern parts but
heavy rain sun to work its way in
cooler fresh conditions up towards the
northwest and it'll feel
a little bit cooler in northerly winds
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now russia is having a record-breaking
summer moscow has seen its hottest dune
day for 120 years
after the temperature hit 34.7
degrees russia's weather service is
apparently forecasting even hotter
weather
in the coming days
coming up border security a pandemic and
an
economic downturn president biden has a
lot
on his plate which means there's plenty
to talk about with our regular us
political experts
scholar and scotty coming up
i think if you look carefully at it what
the bank of england are trying to say
by putting him on the 50-pound note is
that he was about a bit more than
code breaking and there's a lot of
imagery there to do with the
uh foundation of computer science and
so there's a picture of uh a very early
post-war computer and various other
things that are associated with what
alan turing was actually famous for in
his lifetime
when bletchley park was stood a secret
and that was
all that computer development and uh
really i think it's sort of quite nice
to remind ourselves that
his short period of code breaking is not
really the only thing he ought to be
remembered for and indeed i think what
he would
want us to think about in terms of his
legacy is not all this business about
him being prosecuted for being gay
but actually he was always looking
forward to the future he was
trying to sort of invent these machines
that were going to
sort of you know control our lives or be
central to our lives going forward and
these ideas
that he had which are all about the
future and i think we should
think about alan turing in terms of the
future not in terms of the past
i'm tom cheshire and i'm skye's asia
correspondent based here in beijing
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello my name is nadja franchie
my name is ryan matthews i'm the marine
assistant
at rather a research station which is to
the west of the west antarctic peninsula
[Music]
so far i've been here for five months
and it is an absolutely wonderful
experience
my name is fatima zazile the founder of
ikesa from kuwait where we face many
environmental
problems related to waste pollution the
frustration
and lack of information we are
collecting recyclables
from houses schools and businesses in
order to recycle them
exchange if you're recyclable to get a
tree
[Music]
and again in the last hour the
environment secretary has told sky news
he expects
not to be wearing a face covering after
the 19th of july
the government is currently due to drop
all social distancing restrictions
next month uh george eustis told me
he'll choose not to wear a mask if
everything goes to plan what we want to
do
on the 19th of july and the prime
minister said that
the data looks good to be able to have
that end is to remove all of the
legal restrictions that's all of the
legal requirements to do things
to be taken away completely now um
whether there will still be some people
who might choose to wear masks or
whether
it may be advisory in some settings
that's a separate matter but the
the objective of that final stage
is to remove the legal requirement to do
these things okay so from the 19th of
july we won't have to wear our masks
inside as far as the government's
concerned
well as far as because there won't be a
legal compulsion for you too would you
um i wouldn't no i i have to be honest i
uh
once i'm told that it's safe not to uh i
want to get back to normal
i think a lot of people will will want
to um shed those masks
rob powell withers that despite the
world health organization telling us on
sky news yesterday that we really should
still wear our masks inside yeah i think
what the government is trying to do more
broadly is shift away from this putting
it in law getting people to do it and
finding them if they don't and moving to
this sense of personal responsibility i
think that might
rub up against though organizations like
the wh
show that want to see a more muscular
approach but i think what george eustis
was saying
will reassure a lot of backbench
conservative mps that were worried
that some of these elements of
restrictions like wearing masks might
linger around on the statute book
a little longer than july the 19th
george used this confirming that
when those legal restrictions goes that
means that the law saying you have to
wear a mask
goes as well and just a quick thought on
what happened
um yesterday as far as the british
warship
british ship i'm not sure if it's a
warship or not defender and being fired
on by the russians or not
yeah george eustis being pretty punchy i
thought you asked him if
it would travel that route again he said
yes this all comes down to
essentially the uk not recognizing um
the waters it was sailing through as
russian territory as
russia claims it says it is ukrainian
territory because it doesn't recognize
the annexation of korea so
i think there was a degree of chess
beating going on from both sides
just happens that there was two
journalists on hms defender as well and
you can probably read into that
about the reasons why this ship took the
route it did but george used to saying
look
it was legal and we would do it again
okay lovely for now i know you're with
us all morning finale thanks so much rob
thanks a lot
uh been a challenging first seven months
for the new u.s president hasn't it as
well as
covey the vaccination program and the
huge economic downturn he's managed to
roll out a huge financial support
package
as well how has it gone down that and
other questions
with uh lawyer and political and women's
rights activist dr
scholler and also joining us as the
author of oh no i think that
you wrote this is why i resisted it
because it's behind you so obviously you
wrote it
however we can also bring in in the
united states standing by us little
commentator and journalist scotty nell
hughes
ladies it's lovely to have the band back
together thanks for joining us
this morning um shoulder to you first of
all
how do you feel that president biden has
got on
in his first few few months including
his trip to g7
i think joe biden has definitely
demonstrated that america is back
um he has been a you know a breath of
fresh air
not just to america but to the entire
world
in terms of you know the language he's
using the fact that he's getting back on
board and building relationships with
allies the work he has done since the
start of his presidency
with driving the um the kobe vaccination
has been very impressive
it is clear that his administration is
not just listening
to the scientists listening to those who
are invested in this but
they're working closely with them his
message to americans when it comes to
the vaccination
again has been one of inclusiveness the
importance of the importance of
being transparent and why this is
important in addressing the issue of of
course it
um and in terms of the international
perspective i think we can all see
from his recent trip that it was pretty
much welcomed by
all global leaders nobody needed to be
walking on eggshells around
fragile man baby trump um people were
having adult conversations
with an adult um clearly uh
joe biden is also respected because of
his
you know well-established experience in
the foreign you know in the foreign
world in terms of foreign
relations and i think this is really
really good okay i've forgotten how much
he could talk shel to be honest
um scotty's also with us scotty your
thoughts
i i have not i can honestly say i have
not forgotten and
that was exactly what i would expect uh
chola to say
it's a lot easier for my perspective to
be on offense concerning she has to
defend
what an absolutely horrible seven months
it's been here in the united states i'm
so glad that we've got a great pr
machine that's making it look good to
the rest of the world but what we're
actually dealing with here in the united
states is we have
record unemployment of people that do
not want to go back to work because the
government has continued to incentivize
them
to stay home because they'll get paid
more by the government than actually
going back to work so restaurants small
businesses
are suffering saying that they're going
to have to close our gas prices have
almost
doubled since the day joe biden's taken
to office
and that's a lot because here in america
we drive a lot of gas guzzling vehicles
and it takes a lot more our budgets are
actually being stretched with that you
can't buy a house lumber's too expensive
and when you come in regardless to
healthcare and the coveted vaccine our
numbers are so skewed right now
with the reporting of actual people who
have coveted
not even being admit not even being
counted by the cdc anymore
it is such a mess in america today that
i think a lot of americans this morning
when they wake up
would prefer a lot of mean treat mean
tweets if it means they were spending
less at the gas pump and could actually
get what they want and what they were
used to having over the last four years
with president trump oh study
oh my goodness i i have not missed you
i'm sorry listen scotty i've not missed
your
your exaggeration of the fact um you're
definitely missing out on the point that
the government still needs to achieve a
balance before everything can go back
into
full swing whether it's businesses
schools and that's what they've been
trying to do in this past seven months
we're getting people back on board we're
taking the vaccine
in educating people and supporting
businesses
and employees because if they were not
supporting them
how can they achieve a good healthy
balance instead you were saying
get everybody back to work we haven't
really got a handle on this kobe thing
yet
it doesn't matter let's spread the let's
spread the virus especially with this
delta variant going on
a balance has to be achieved and can i
just say before you start throwing
unemployment and everything out there i
think the figures are showing that it's
much better
than it was last year so as far as as
far as i see it
we're still trying to take a handle of
this pandemic
we are not you know it's not all slot
free yet and that is what this
government is trying to is trying to
address
don't get me wrong scotty if there's
something to criticize
i will criticize it that doesn't mean i
would not be supporting buying scrubbing
they do something wrong i will call it
out
but what i'm saying is the government
that's trying to achieve a balance
in getting people to be vaccinated and
the numbers of that is going higher not
lower
scotty but that's i agree maybe things
are a little different over the uk but
here in the usa
we're pretty much back open in fact by
an administration
and even some of the most leftist
progressive mayors in america have done
everything they can
we're open people just don't want to go
back to work because the government
checks are rolling in and it is not a
good time here and if you're talking
about balance does that mean going
completely from things being stability
to being high cost high prices and
things that you can't live
is that the balance you're looking for
yeah you're right things are back back
to leading from behind which is exactly
the policies that we found and exactly
why on the international scale there is
so much disrespect right now for this
country
on the foreign scale oh my month seven
wasn't completely wait
hold on let's talk about it because
right now you already have all those
countries in the g7 yesterday it was
announced
germany the eu even the uk are going to
sit down with russia
and talk about the nordstrom that's
exactly not
what biden had said that he wanted to do
he wanted to put the pressure on putin
and russia and yet
now it's the exact opposite it was a
complete joke unfortunately to see and i
think
every country has a different experience
with bayern last year
last week to see exactly what americans
are dealing with and why
we are in the chaotic structure that
we're in today okay study my
my dear study let me just remind you
because it's clear you are suffering
from selective amnesia you want to talk
about
disrespect disrespect was the last four
years with donald trump
disrespect was how donald trump you know
he dealt with all of our allies
how he separated us from our allies how
he
you know basically was kissing the butts
of you know
of north korea and russia that was
disrespect
what you're finding right now because at
the end are you kidding me yesterday
with each other let's go right in the
middle to engage
with russia should they wish to america
does not control
other countries this is about dialogue
it's about debate it's not
one you know a common consensus okay
that's coming
back scotty
there is unity right now going on
between the eu germany the uk
with russia something that the u.s did
not want that was very evident going
into it but you cannot look at the chaos
that has happened over the last seven
months
within the middle east within china with
everything going on and say yes oh the
world is getting along right now
actually it's not and that's right there
because you don't have
that leadership now what i am seeing is
actually everybody is continuing to
try to aim towards peace because we are
can we have a pandemic
but it's not including the usa because
the usa has enough problems at its own
borders
and within its own country that luckily
it should be able to fill their agenda
and keep us busy and keep us out of the
world's business if we could be so lucky
we've got enough problems here at home
thanks to this administration
ladies ladies we are out of time i am so
sorry it's
so lovely to have you back we properly
miss you i've got an all-girl gallery in
my ear today and they were saying
how great it was to have the girls back
in town hopefully we'll see you soon
time next week thank you so much
great to see thank you how lovely
uh let's tell you about um did you ever
have mcafee software on you on your
computer
uh well it was named after the
entrepreneur john mcafee he's been found
dead
in his prison cell in barcelona
why was he there what happened somebody
who can fill us in is michelle clifford
standing by in brussels
hi michelle good morning what do we know
well he was in jail in spain because he
was wanted on
um tax evasion charges by the u.s
justice
uh department the u.s had been seeking
his extradition yesterday
the spanish authorities granted that
extradition
hours later he was found dead in
a prison cell in barcelona now the
authorities say
prison officers tried to revive him they
were unsuccessful but they say that all
the indications are
that he took his own life and he was a
very much
a successful character you mentioned um
the software the antivirus software but
he was also
a greatly controversial character okay
uh his time in jail in barcelona was not
his first brush with the law he'd spent
time in a dominican republic
uh jail um after being accused of
traveling with others on a yacht with
high caliber
weapons on board he had also been named
as a person
of interest in the past over the murder
of a neighbor in belize he always denied
uh those charges um he had said in
recent years
that there was a plot to get him he'd
also alleged in the past
that his enemies have tried to kill him
a controversial
uh character but one a man who will be
remembered for his success
in the technology industry okay michelle
thanks so much indeed thanks a lot one
of the main stories we're covering this
morning
is what's happened to britney spears she
was in court
uh yesterday she's asked for a
conservatorship order
to be overturned um why what is it
what does it mean what happens next
hopefully we can answer some of those
questions with perez hilton american
blogger joining us now hello to you good
morning thanks for joining us
um talk to us about this court
appearance what
how has it come to this and what happens
next
it's come to this because the court has
not
listened to britney spears and what
she's
shared with them we heard today in her
own words
at her request that this was made public
because actually at the beginning of
today's hearing there was a motion made
to keep everything closed but brittany
herself said no
she wanted the public to hear what she
had to say
in 2019 she went before this judge
in a closed hearing and told this judge
that she did
not want to be in the conservatorship
anymore and she's had to endure another
two years of this
she's called this traumatic she says
that she cries
every day and that has been forced to do
things
against her will like performing while
sick
not being granted a break being forced
to go from one vegas residency to
another
and just sounding just
completely like a like a broken woman
but defiant at the same time
um you've not always been complimentary
about it have you perry's i mean we have
to put that out there
looking back how do you feel about some
of the things you said about her and
whether or not it contributed
potentially to her mental health
challenges
yeah you know i take full accountability
for how i behave in the past i can't say
oh i was just
young and dumb i think we know a lot
more
and initially many folks
myself included were shocked and alarmed
and especially concerned
for her young children and i know that i
did not express myself as well as i
could have i didn't lead
with empathy and compassion which
thankfully it seems like most people now
are understanding the severity of
britney's situation but i absolutely
apologize
and carry just deep shame and regret
um how do you feel towards her father
oh yeah yeah um
in 2008 i am
many others thought that jamie spears
saved
his daughter i i was really worried that
had this conservatorship not been put in
place
that britney could have ended up dead we
forget
but she was really putting herself in
dangerous situations
almost every single day going out in the
city
by herself without a security team
ending up in a hotel
talking to strangers it was a very scary
time
so i think you know we often hear
where's the family why isn't anybody
stepping up and helping out
well her dad did and as brittany herself
said in court on wednesday
that old expression money is the root of
all evil
for 13 years now she says her entire
family has been living off of her and
this conservatorship and
what may have started off with good
intentions has
become corrupt over the years so do you
think that it was the right thing to do
back in 2008 but it's just gone on for
too long is that what you're saying
well i used to think it was the right
thing to do
because that's what we were told we were
told that britney was in such
poor shape but recently the new york
times the paper of record
shared with the world that when
britney's father
filed the paperwork to put her under a
conservatorship
that he checked off dementia
after hearing her speak today
clearly i'm not a doctor or a medical
expert
it's dubious that she has
dementia so i had to now question
everything over the last 13 years
brittany also said that you know she
didn't know that she could
end the conservatorship by just putting
in a request
so hopefully you know there's another
hearing scheduled for next month
uh hopefully it's the positive hearing
with a positive update that
you know brittany can finally be free
like she wants
and then what and then what for her do
you think
well britney said that she wants to get
married and wants to have another child
but she does not have say over her
own body the conservatorship doesn't
just control her finances it
controls her medication and clearly
forcing her to have contraception
uh you know hopefully nothing bad
happens
after whenever if she hopefully
is no longer in the conservatorship but
the overwhelming majority of people who
have
who suffer from severe mental health
issues are not
in conservatorships so why should
britney spears be in one
is it just because of money and then i
think of the question of free will
you know if britney wants to spend all
of her money
gamble it do whatever she wants with it
shouldn't
she be able to she also brought up the
question
or the subject of manner many of money
many times
during her court appearance on wednesday
i just want to ask you before i let you
go
um you you've you know fulsome apology
for things that you've said about her in
the past
if you could sit down and chat to her
now over tea or whatever what would you
say
i well i emailed i emailed britney a
letter
last year and i apologized
privately as well as publicly but i
would just want to hug her
i just want to hug her i'm vaccinated
and
i i think she is too from what i've seen
on social media she shared that she got
at least one
dose i think she just needs love because
i cannot imagine
the betrayal and the sadness and the
emptiness that she must feel
believing and knowing and experiencing
this total lack of just not
support and not being there for her from
her entire
family her mother her father her brother
her sister
it's soul crushing um thanks for staying
up
late to talk to us here in the uk sleep
well thanks for taking the time
thank you paris hilton speaking to us um
about his regrets over what he said
about brittany in the past and how he
has
apologized privately and publicly to her
what will happen to brittany next she
was in court of course
yesterday to try uh to break free from
her father more on that in the next hour
and also will you wear a mask
after the 19th of july it won't be
compulsory anymore
government minister says he won't what
will you do
more on that in just a moment stay tuned